good afternoon as many of you know this
is the week at Columbia when we are
privileged to welcome presidents prime
ministers and global policymakers to
campus each of them a world leader who
comes here to express his or her views
and to engage especially our students
directly on the most pressing issues
facing societies for several reasons
this particular columbia world leaders
forum stands out on the calendar and
carries very special significance for
our university community first and
foremost we are very happy to have the
opportunity to hear from dr. ted gross
who became the director-general of the
World Health Organization in July in
addition to welcoming you to Columbia
dr. Ted Rose we offer you our
congratulations and our best wishes for
you as you begin your term as
director-general World Health
Organization is responsible for
addressing the most serious public
health challenges facing humanity from
emerging pandemics and antibiotic
resistant infections to the health
effects of climate change indeed these
matters have for some time occupied the
focused attention of a large number of
this University's scholars across our
campuses and at our global centers and
so we have been honored that the w-h-o
designated Columbia's International
Research Institute as a partner in
predicting disease outbreaks resulting
from climate change dr. Ted Rose is
especially well suited to shoulder this
responsibility during his tenure as
Ethiopia's Minister of Health
he vastly expanded access to quality
medical care by instituting fundamental
reforms in the nation
health care system he also served as
Ethiopia's Minister of Foreign Affairs I
know we are all looking forward to
hearing about his plans for the World
Health Organization second today marks
the launch of the new Colombia program
on global health security and diplomacy
this is a cross-disciplinary effort
involving the medical center of the
School of International and public
affairs and the earth Institute's
International Research Institute for
climate and society it will be led by
dr. Wilma James and dr. Madeleine
Thompson dr. James who will moderate the
panel following dr. Ted Rose address was
for several years a member a South of
South Africa's Parliament and provided
leadership to that nation on a range of
public health matters in a ministerial
capacity he is a visiting professor at
the Columbia University Medical Center
and at the School of International and
public affairs third this event provides
us with an opportunity to take stock of
how the university is helping to address
problems of global dimension especially
at this consequential moment in world
history it is important for Columbia to
be pondering its responsibilities in
this regard and we have been Global
society's challenges are more sharply
delineated than ever before all I have
to do is say that with emphasis and
everybody knows what I mean and it has
become increasingly clear that 20th
century institutions and norms are not
sufficient for addressing the complexity
and scale of these problems and with
this in mind we have launched a
far-reaching new initiative called
Columbia World projects a development
that will I think have a profound effect
on research teaching and scholarship
Columbia in the coming years it's
central purpose is to harness the
university's capacities and knowledge in
the service of practical solutions
always with an openness to even
insistence on working across but even
beyond disciplines and with partners
beyond academia following the remarks of
dr. Ted Rose we will be hearing from a
panel that includes Elizabeth Cameron
who has become a senior director at the
nuclear threat initiative after serving
on President Obama's National Security
Council Gavin Schmidt the director of
NASA Goddard Institute for Space Studies
at the Columbia University Earth
Institute and our well-known Jeff Sachs
for all of us know and appreciate the
extraordinary leadership he has provided
to this university and to the United
Nations and Beyond upon sustainable
development and far more we thank all of
you and our speaker dr. Ted Rose for the
contributions that you are making to
improve global health and well-being now
please join me in welcoming the World
Health Organisation's new
director-general dr. tetanus
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much for that
kind introduction dear president
Bollinger my brother professor Sachs
distinguished colleagues ladies and
gentlemen before I begin my address let
me first express my deep personal
concern for the people of the Caribbean
islands they suffer this relentless wave
of hurricanes this is a further reminder
of the merciless consequences of our
changing climate
shattered homes shattered lives wh a
stands ready to do all we can do to
assist but now let me take you on a
journey it starts with a single case in
a military camp in Kansas a cook reports
to the Medical Center complaining of
fever a sore throat and eggs and pains
within minutes a second soldier is
admitted with similar symptoms by
lunchtime the count has reached more
than 100 and more than 500 by the end of
the week the following week the virus
reached New York Manhattan but Islands
from the camp are sent to fight a war in
foreign lands they're confined living
quarters and massive movements of troops
provide the ideal conditions for the
virus to spread within months the
epidemic
sweeps across five continents it's
symptoms include nausea diarrhea and
dark spots on the cheeks the virus takes
hold patients turn blue and suffocate
their lungs fill with blood there are no
vaccines to stop the virus and no drugs
to treat it many of its victims are
young cut down in their most productive
years schools places of worship theaters
and other public places are closed here
in New York businesses closing times are
staggered in order to avoid congestion
on public transport phenols are limited
to 15 minutes there is a shortage of
coffins and then suddenly and in
explicably as it started the pandemic
ends one third of the world's population
has been infected including 25 percent
of the u.s. population 50 million people
are dead this is not some future a
pocket-like apocalyptic scenario this
happened as you may know hundred years
ago the so called Spanish flu which may
in fact have started here in the u.s.
killed more people than the first world
war itself and yet it was overshadowed
by the war and faded quickly from public
awareness its lessons are just as
relevant today as they were
and that a devastating epidemic can
start in any country at any time and
kill millions of people because we are
not prepared but we do not have to
stretch back that far to be reminded of
the fearsome consequences of epidemics
just this century we have witnessed
outbreaks of Silas h1n1 h5n1 MERS and
h7n9 each of this has resulted in deaths
sickness fear and economic loss of
course the most traumatic epidemics of
our time was the Ebola outbreak of 2014
and 2015 although it affected three poor
western Africa countries it exposed
fault lines in global health security
that put us all at risk its severity was
caused in large part by weaknesses of
the health system which were
ill-equipped to detect or track Ebola
and we're soon stretched beyond the
limited capacity to respond it was not
just the Ebola virus itself which killed
in Liberia the epidemic contributed to a
16 percent decline in outpatient visits
Sara Lian explains experienced a 39
percent drop in children being treated
for malaria and a 21 percent drop in
children receiving basic immunizations
you know what could happen to these kids
in Guinea primary medical consultations
and hospitalizations dropped by more
than half and vaccinations by one-third
compared to 2013 in short the whole
health system
elapsed the shockwaves of epidemics are
always felt well beyond the devastated
families and long after the last
survivors lived treatment centers in
2003 SARS caused loss of up to 59
billion his dollars according to the
Asian Development Bank in 2009 the h1n1
pandemic wiped 2.8 billion US dollars of
Mexico's tourism industry and led to
pork to a pork trade deficit of 27
billion his dollars as a result of the
Ebola outbreak the International
Monetary Fund reduced its growth
projections for all of sub-saharan
Africa by 10 percent
Ebola also caused commodity prices to
plummet and led to higher unemployment
and physical deficits Ebola taught us a
valuable lesson global health security
is only as strong as its weakest link
I repeat global health Security's only
as strong as its weakest links let's put
it in another way no one is safe until
we are all safe
this means all countries need to have
resilient and robust local health
systems to prevent detect and respond to
public health emergencies at national
level we must support governments to
build that capacity every month
wh-wha screams around 5,000 signals of
new outbreaks across the world we
monitor this carefully because ignoring
any one of them can be the difference
between global spread of a deadly
disease and rapid interruption of
transmission every day somewhere in the
world double nature is out in the field
with local
officials investigating a potential
outbreak when an alert is sounded early
enough as when Ebola broke in the
Democratic Republic of the Congo earlier
this year we can move quickly to support
government's and stop the outbreak at
its source that outbreak in the
Democratic Republic of Congo was
contained in just few weeks also too
frequently the tragic tragedy of war
creates the perfect conditions for
disease to spread when others
infrastructure is damaged or destroyed
when health workers are targeted and
killed when essential medicines cannot
get through to the people who need them
most
the world's defenses against epidemics
start to crumble it was no coincidence
that Spanish flu the greatest epidemic
erupted in the middle of what was then
the greatest war the world had known it
was no coincidence that Ebola spread in
countries that have suffered from years
of war it's no accident that coal era is
sickening thousands in Yemen as we speak
of course epidemics are not the only
threat to global security natural
disasters biological and chemical
attacks food insecurity and the effects
of climate change all have the potential
to put people's health at risk that's
specially true for antimicrobial
resistance the world's ability to
respond to infectious disease has been
seriously undermined by its failure to
ensure that medicines remain effective
many commanders have now become
resistant to the drugs we have and few
replacements are in the pipeline in fact
today we are launching a new report
about the state of research and
development for new treatments against
some of the bacteria that pose the
biggest threat
to him and health it shows that the
carport is disturbingly bare
we have nothing urgent investments in
research and development are needed but
we also need new thinking about ways to
incentivize our partners in the
pharmaceutical industry to make those
investments but research and development
is not a panicky action is needed across
all sectors for example we are working
closely with the common industry to
understand how MERS is crossing from
animals into humans we collaborate with
the agriculture sector to detect monitor
and respond to influenza viruses with
pandemic potential but same time as we
prepare for outbreaks and other health
emergencies we must address one of the
most pervasive root cause of health
insecurity the lack of access of the
most vulnerable people to essential
health services without inverse that has
coverage there can be no global health
security there are two sides of the same
coin universal health coverage is based
on the moral conviction that health is a
human right that we refused to accept a
wounded in which people get sick and die
simply because they are poor it means
simply put that everyone can get the
health services they need when and where
they need them without facing financial
hardship it sounds obvious if only it
was but the reality that more than 400
million people around the world that
lack access to essential health services
there are some people who argue that the
estimate is actually more than 400
million and at least 100 million people
are pushed into poverty every single
year because of the costs of paying for
care out of their own pockets it's
important to emphasize that embezzlers
coverage is more than
in verse and healthcare yes it includes
care but it also means that people can
get care without risking financial ruin
after all what good are health services
if people don't use them because they
can't afford them but in verse of this
coverage also goes beyond individual
health services to those that promote
health and prevent disease at the
population level many of this do not
even need health infrastructure or
health workers to be effective such as
tobacco taxation and promoting healthy
eating a health system that's delivering
universal health coverage also includes
periodic services such as immunization
and screening a strong network of
primary care clinics of everyday health
needs and the ability to provide more
complex care in hospitals when we
describe our systems in distance our
minds may immediately jump to the
wealthy economies of Western Europe but
we should also think of countries such
as China Rwanda Chile Thailand and
Turkey all of which have made giant
strides both in improving access to
health services and in making those
services affordable for their people
take China in the past 20 years China
has made large investments in its health
infrastructure making health services
more equally accessible to its bus
population the result has been large
declines in child and maternal mortality
improved health outcomes and increase
life expectancy in Rwanda health system
reforms over the past 15 years including
the provision of preventive services
free of charge to the entire population
have also meant that more mothers
survive childbirth and more children get
to celebrate their fifth birthday pro
honda's community
there is Insurance Scheme covers more
than 80% of the population in a country
where 90% of people work in the informal
sector actually here is the point far
from being a luxury that only rich
countries can afford evidence and
experience both show that in Versalles
coverage is an is within reach for all
countries at all income levels every
nation can do more with the resources it
has the recent whu-oh study shows that
85% of the costs of achieving the health
targets in the SDGs can be met from
domestic resources those investments
would prevent 97 million premature
deaths globally by 2030 and add as much
as eight point four years to life
expectancy in some countries yes some of
the poorest countries will continue to
need aid but for the majority in their
service coverage is affordable and
achievable more than that universal
health coverage is politically smart
because just as epidemics can cripple an
economy universal health coverage can
help it grow strong resilient systems
are integral to strong resilient
economies the logic is clear when people
are healthy entire communities and
nations thrive when children survived to
adulthood they become productive members
of society when women survive childbirth
they can return to working or caring for
their families when communities are free
from pollution harmful products and
other causes of disease they prosper
simple and everybody knows this too
often
governments see the health sector as a
cost to be contained and this is wrong
rather than held as an investment
to be nurtured but the return on
investment in health is very compelling
the world's top economists estimate that
every single dollar spent on health
yields up to 20 US dollars in full
income grows within a generation the
health sector is also a growing source
of jobs among OECD countries employment
in the health and social sectors grew by
48 percent between 2000 and 2014 while
jobs in industry and agriculture
declined and because 70% of the global
health workforce is female jobs for
health workers are jobs for women all of
this means that for most countries the
only real barrier is political will the
only real barrier is political will
without exception every country with
universal health coverage or something
close to it has got their because at
some point in its history its leaders
acted with foresight courage and moral
conviction that is making a difference
between countries not resources there is
no single path to UHC every country must
find its own way
in the context of its own social
political and economic circumstances but
the starting point is a determination to
create a health system that on one hand
protects individuals and families from
incapacitating illness and financial
catastrophe and on the other guards
against health threats that can hobble
an entire economy so what can we do in
my first week as Director General I was
honored to be invited by Chancellor
Angela Merkel to address the g20 in
Hamburg on this very topic of health
security I will tell you what I told
them first we need to support countries
to make progress toward the cinders and
Hills coverage by strengthening health
systems especially in the most fragile
and vulnerable parts of the world and
those in the grip of conflict this is
what WH er does all around the world
every day it's not always glamorous work
but it's extremely important second we
must prioritize research and development
of new medical countermeasures through
WH AHS research and development
blueprint which identifies the pathogens
that are the most likely to spark an
epidemic developing new vaccines and
drugs is not the whole solution but it's
an important part of it
third it's vital that we map global
capacities for emergency preparedness
and response unless we know which
countries have which capacities it's
impossible to deploy them quickly when a
fire starts it's the wrong time to ask
where the extinguishers are and fifth
time fourth force
regular exercises are needed to stress
test our plans we find our processes and
check logistics this is like a military
drilling or simulation exercises regular
again and it with a polemic is the wrong
time to discover our preparations have
been sufficient or that we have
overlooked crucial components of the
response finally and fifth we need to
sub sustainably finance the global
health security system to prevent detect
and respond to threats governments must
walk the talk to ensure a guaranteed
level of contingency financing for
health emergencies financing when there
is panic doesn't help I think we have to
finance it during normal times and
prepare for it delivering on these
priorities will cost money but only a
fraction of
what's remaining unprepared with costs
ladies and gentlemen we do not know
where or when the next global pandemic
will occur but we do not we do know that
it will exact a terrible toll was on
human life and on the global economy and
even may cause political instability but
we do not have to stand idly by and wait
for disaster to strike we can be
prepared outbreaks are inevitable but
epidemics are preventable this is not
only a job for those of us in the health
sector everyone has a role to play from
those who ensure the safety of our food
to those who try to strive for safety in
our world preventing conflict helps
prevent disease - and peace and security
also is important guarding against
epidemics and building resilient health
systems requires the tournament shawls
and bright minds to prevent disease and
to prevent conflict - you know how our
world is profoundly changing in a very
negative way for those reasons I'm
tremendously encouraged that inversely
with the stature of Colombia is
launching a global health security and
diplomacy program what a fitting and
maybe a gift for me to equip future
health leaders with the knowledge and
skills to solve the complex challenges
we face I wish you every success and
look forward to working with you very
closely I thank you thank you very much
thank you very much to dr. tetras for
his leadership at the w-h-o and his
vision for advancing the goals of global
health my name as you heard is what my
James and I'm a South African Member of
Parliament on leave to Columbia
University to spend a year as a visiting
professor in non clinical pediatrics and
International Affairs it is a novel
joint appointment and ties together the
field of international affairs but the
business of medicine and public health
before I invite our esteemed respondents
to react to dr. tethers address it's my
pleasure tonight to introduce you to the
working group on health security in
diplomacy and the program that goes by
the same name that I'm honored to lead
together with my colleague dr. Madeleine
Thompson from the earth Institute at
Columbia University since July yeah I've
been working with colleagues in medicine
in public health climate science social
science and international affairs in
putting together and interdisciplinary
and inter-sectoral program in our
security and diplomacy described in a
browser you will find on your seat the
purpose of the program as this is a
university is to educate and train a new
generation of our security and diplomacy
researchers professionals and leaders in
a context of all described by Columbia
President Lee Bollinger and dr. Ted Russ
by immersing them in the best available
medical public health climate science
and diplomatic knowledge there is and
with a special focus on the needs and
interests of children
it is a great opportunity for Colombia
to build such a program at a time when
the current administration in the u.s.
sends our other strong signals that it
seeks to pull back from its global
leadership role in health because the
fact is that the world today faces both
all the neuroses to health they are
global in scope to which all of us with
resources and equities must contribute
to managing because no single
institution all government can do so on
its own it is and must be a shared
responsibility driven by a single common
purpose of advancing human health
worldwide our program focus on the
medicine the public of the climate
science and diplomacy of Alvarez
management is portrayed in the slide it
is with this introduction that I invite
dr. Jeffrey Sachs to respond to dr.
tetras Jeffrey Sachs as you know
requires no introduction but I will
nevertheless point out that is a
professor of economics is a leader of
development and he is an author and
columnist of note is the founder of the
earth Institute the author of the
Millennium Development Goals and an
advisor at the highest level to the
United Nations and governments worldwide
I have our Steam as I have the other
respondents since I have to moderate the
panel and I want to allow for discussion
and questions which you may not know is
by tradition only to be asked by
students at the end and so would you
please welcome dr. Jeff Sachs
[Applause]
welcome and thanks we're in good hands
don't you agree we're really in
wonderful hands with Tetris at the helm
of w-h-o it's a crucial institution at a
very complicated time and I'm profoundly
gratified that you have highlighted
every one of the major challenges we
still have basic challenges of the most
basic health in poor countries still six
million kids are dying every year under
the age of five overwhelmingly in very
poor places overwhelmingly of readily
preventable and treatable diseases so
that's one kind of crisis that's very
significant we have as you said the
emerging and re-emerging diseases we've
been battered now throughout human
history but especially in recent decades
by one new disease after another
remember that aids itself is a zoonosis
of a century ago that because of the
meagre surveillance was circulating in
Africa infecting millions and millions
of people for an estimated 60 years and
was not determined until it was
identified in San Francisco in 1981
that's a pretty pathetic and very tragic
fact because the zoonosis itself the
event that had probably triggered the
emergence of AIDS took place somewhere
in West Africa probably around 1920
and this is how bad our surveillance is
but the the risks are absolutely obvious
the irony of Public Health is it's such
an incredibly good field it's so capable
so smart that you get an incredible
amount for very very little you know
it's not a lot of money to save millions
and millions of lives per year and yet
raising that little amount of money is
sometimes unbelievably difficult how big
the fights were to get AIDS treatment
started how big the fights were to get
some kind of organized malaria response
how big the fights are right now to help
poor countries to deploy community
health workers I've been on this note
together with my wife Sonya who is you
know leads a campaign for community
health workers worldwide and even in the
middle of the Ebola epidemic it was not
possible to get coherent response from
the international institutions pathetic
by the way just absolutely pathetic the
World Bank which I'm on an email
exchange with today just cannot put one
foot in front of the next to actually
get financing out Global Fund which I
helped to start seventeen years ago some
time and which Tedros chaired for
brilliant period sometimes can't move
even when it's absolutely urgent to move
then there are the complexities and
challenges that are quite different from
those of poverty though they're
spreading to poor countries as you said
the the food industry is killing us and
this is quite hard because the food
industry is powerful it is got the vast
lobbying and it is
an industry that produces obesogenic
products that has made about 40% of
adult Americans obese and addicted to
just completely unhealthy things and of
course the more you travel the world the
more you come back to the United States
you say that is not food what what we
see here it is not food it is organic
probably mostly but it is not food and
it's just horrible what's happening and
this is one of the great health threats
that we face but it's very political
just as tobacco is very political even
when you know it you can identify it you
know that sugar beverages are horrible
for health and for mental well-being and
for many other things we can't move
because modern capitalism I always say I
want to be in a business next time that
has an addicted product you know you get
lots of customers all the time and this
is how our system works is build
addictions make large profits hire lots
of lobbyists and sustain the addiction
as long as possible whether it's tobacco
or soda or oil and gas and coal it's
basically the same same model right now
so we also have a big problem of
research and development that I just
want to touch on briefly the u.s. is
incredibly productive right now in world
science is incredibly productive in new
research but we are going backwards on
bringing the research to access and as
we've privatized research increasingly
and big private money goes into research
which is a tribute to our capital
markets we are producing more and more
breakthrough drugs that are being priced
at $100,000
a treatment dose 300,000 now the new
cancer drugs are at $500,000 a treatment
dose this is really broken we have a
cure for hepatitis C which is a
wonderful drug developed by a small
biotech company with NIH support called
Pharma set it was purchased by Gilead in
2011 for 11 billion dollars
this chemical sofosbuvir I it passed the
final phase three trials and then Gilead
has been marketing it since 2012 the
pills cost $1 to make they charge $1,000
a pill it's 7 weeks
84 pills for a treatment dose so for
what costs 84 dollars to manufacture
they're charging eighty four thousand
dollars now of course there's some
discounts they always tell me oh it's
only forty thousand if you take the
discounts so the strategy is that we
have a system where there are two or
three million Hep C infected people and
they're dying slowly of liver disease
and the government is the only provider
really except for some high cost private
insurance and the government says well
you have to be pretty far gone before
we're gonna treat you and so people are
basically told when you're near death
come back and then you can get a this
drug now if this drug were mass applied
we would actually end hepatitis C
because this is a full cure this is not
like HIV this is a full cure we could
not only break transmission we could end
the disease so this is a horrific
misapplication of
rights absolutely horrific and I find it
fascinating when I write about it I get
lots of hate mail from Wall Street that
says what are you talking about
and I often in an email I write back
people are dying and serious people
write back so so I read people are dying
large numbers so that's how our system
works professor Sachs get over it and
that really is a mental disease because
that is not a system that is producing
results and if we provide lots of
wonderful new $500,000.00 treatments for
cancers that's not a system that is
doing what it needs to do so this is yet
another challenge because we're on a
absolute scientific revolution right now
but we do not have a model of social
justice to go along with the Scientific
Revolution so all of this is to say that
you've got your hands full we love you
and we want to help you thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much to dr. Sachs
if I cannot call on Beth Cameron who is
the senior director for global
biological policy and programs at the
nuclear threats initiative
she previously served as a senior
director for global security and by the
fence at the White House at the National
Security Council in the previous
administration where she was
instrumental in launching the global
health security agenda and worked in the
following areas in biosecurity by a
defense emerging infectious diseases the
earliest research and bioterrorism
welcome
thank you very much dr. James thanks for
inviting me and thanks for hosting this
event and most importantly dr. Ted Rose
thank you for your leadership what I'm
gonna speak about is a little bit about
the future of the global health security
agenda which is an organ it's just
basically an organization of countries
nongovernmental organization sector the
private sector and next generation
leaders that exist to support the WH
o--'s effort to implement the
International Health Regulations and
what you'll see is that everything I'm
going to say just stresses and
emphasizes what we've already heard from
you tonight
under your great leadership at WH o so
first first and foremost in global
health security WH OHS leadership is
essential and not only wh o but also the
world Organization for Animal Health oae
and the Food and Agricultural
organization of the UN FAO and there's a
great tripartite leadership that happens
between those organizations which is
incredible to see and absolutely
essential to the challenges that dr. Ted
Rose outlined I don't have to convince
this audience after hearing from dr. Ted
Rose that pandemics are critical and I
think the story that you told that the
1918 flu was absolutely the most
poignant reflection of this issue but I
do think it's important especially at an
academic university and for those of you
in the audience who may not be in
government to think a little bit not
only about health but how health impacts
security and national security as a
staffer in the White House during the
Ebola crisis I saw firsthand what
happens to heads of state in governments
very far from affected countries who are
having a hard time wrapping their head
around what the Ebola outbreak in West
Africa might mean for them and there was
absolutely a need for intellectual
capital coming out of our universities
coming out of our civil society to
inform the government in that situation
and so I'm so pleased to hear about the
new center that's being launched here
today and I think that health diplomacy
is going to be
absolutely vital field for the future
and I encourage some of the students in
the audience to consider it we need you
and whu-oh needs you so the global
health security agenda is an isn't
voluntary organization of countries that
was launched actually after the first
cases of Ebola occurred in Guinea but
before they were reported to w-h-o and
so this was put together in response to
the fact that less than 20% of countries
actually made the deadline for
implementing the World Health
Organization's international health
regulations and so the GHSA was launched
in February of 2014 with the w-h-o the
FAO the OIE and a number of like-minded
countries from all over the world with
different backgrounds different levels
of development and different kinds of
health systems with the idea that
countries and sectors so not just the
health sector but ministries of Finance
ministries of Foreign Affairs ministries
of Defense needed to come together to
talk about all of the different facets
of global health security from
naturally-occurring disease threats to
at lab accidents to bioterrorism
countries were asked to make specific
commitments those commitments were asked
to be made and then reported back on
over a period of time and the goal there
was really to raise attention to the
level of heads of state which has been
very successful as dr. Ted Rose
mentioned the g20 the g7 have focused on
this for the last couple of cycles and
that's something that I think is
absolutely vital to be maintained and
I'm so happy that this is happening here
during the UN General Assembly because
this is an issue that really needs to
stay on the radar screen of heads of
state just like climate change just like
terrorism just like other transnational
threats also to incentivize
accountability accountability within
governments for their own health system
but also accountability of those who say
and make commitments that they're going
to help others how is that actually
happening how is it happening in country
and how our donors actually coordinating
and tracking progress together more
effectively that's something that I
consistently heard when I was an
implementer working with and in
countries that was
very confusing often how the funding was
actually being tracked and measured and
obviously from your experience now and
throughout your career this is something
I've heard from global health leaders
across the board so really important to
be accountable and then ultimately the
background of this slide is not just
because it's a pretty colour it's
actually the cover of a report that was
put out earlier this year called the
International Working Group on pandemic
preparedness financing you heard from
dr. Ted Rose the important the absolute
importance of financing health and
health security and this turns out to be
a non-trivial feat it's not just about
asking for money it's about sustaining
capability over a long term period
ultimately to break this cycle where we
panic when we have an outbreak and spend
lots of money and then neglect the
period where we don't have one where
those investments are actually less
costly and more important so the global
health security agenda in close
partnership with a w-h-o has made a
number of different achievements but the
one that I just really quickly want to
highlight actually I'll highlight two in
green the importance of metrics and so
through the global health security
agenda working with w-h-o a set of
targets have now been adopted for the
International Health Regulations which
have been folded into the w-h-o external
evaluations for ihr implementation this
process was critical and if you had
asked me when we launched GHSA if we
would have gotten to this point and I
think if you launched if you'd asked
most of my colleagues at whu-oh they
would have said no having peer
assessments come in two countries and
looking at health security capacity and
then publishing the results it's never
gonna happen
but it has happened in w-h-o now has a
huge team under Peter Salama that has
now done assessments in 50 countries
working with experts around the world
and that absolutely needs to continue
and I know is being strongly supported
under dr. Ted roses leadership but GHSA
has also become a platform for bringing
in the private sector for bringing in
academic universities for bringing in
civil society and I think that's a place
where organizations like the center
that's being launched here
today at Columbia can play an absolutely
critical role how do you take specific
goals in global health security rally
communities around them in a measurable
way and then actually monitor and
evaluate the progress over time that's
one of the questions we asked when GHSA
was launched and it's a place where
progress has been made but a lot more
progress especially from the
non-governmental sector really does need
to continue I mentioned the joint
external evaluations and on the right
side of the slide it's just an example
of what one of the evaluations results
actually looks like and I highlight this
example because it's what most countries
look like there's a lot of yellow a
little bit of green and some red and the
goal here is to turn all of that red and
yellow into green and to keep it green
and we can't do that unless we're
actually actively evaluating and
supporting countries to get prepared so
the last thing that I'll say quickly is
I'll just highlight three challenges in
global health security that I think the
global health security agenda is focused
on but I know that also w-h-o is focused
on as well one is leveraging the
commitments that are out there so
through the last couple of g7 and g20
cycles many high-level commitments have
been made this is just one example that
the g7 has made a commitment to assist
76 countries and regions to implement
the international health regulations
that's a fantastic commitment but it's
really hard to track down who's done
what for how long and to measure the
results and I think that's another place
where civil society can really help by
measuring results by looking at what's
been done and by helping keep countries
on track for the commitments that
they've made second I mentioned the
countability
and I think if you look at what the
ultimate goal here is there'll be an
external evaluation in every country
every country will have a national plan
by every country I don't just mean
countries that have had more challenges
with our health system I mean every
country the United States went through a
joint external evaluation when I was at
the White House and we found problems
that needed to be fixed find it having a
national plan financing the knife
plan having the political commitment to
keep that financing going and then
ultimately continuing that effort by
helping others to get prepared to and so
the non-governmental global health
security agenda consortium put out a
call for the upcoming ministerial for
GHSA which will be held in Kampala
Uganda next month and we asked by 2019
could 75 countries realistically have a
national plan based on the work whu-oh
is doing and could those national plans
actually be financed could there be a
sustainable financing strategy in place
this is a huge goal and we put it out
there a lot of people thought it might
not be achievable but I ask those of you
in the audience and dr. Ted Rose to
consider this this goal because
ultimately if a country has a finance
national plan it's more likely that
they'll actually be able to implement it
get prepared and then finally just to
really emphasize - foot stomp a point
that dr. Ted Rose made which is looking
at health security is really important
in and of itself but it's vital to look
at health security in the broader
context of health systems across the
board and also universal health coverage
so these are issues that leaders have
focused on over the last several years
more and more under dr. Ted roses
leadership and with continuing interest
from countries around the world
universal health coverage is becoming an
important issue Global Health security
shouldn't compete with this it should
actually complement it so being prepared
for pandemic threats is part of your
overall health system and part of access
to care and services and we saw how
those things were intertwined very up
close and personally during the Ebola
outbreak and so just urging those of you
that work in this field to think about
these not as competing priorities but as
three areas that actually all need to
get attention and focus and I'll just
stop there and say that I'm incredibly
pleased to be here and thank you again
and thank you dr. Ted Restrepo
I must say that the panelists are
extremely disciplined thank you very
much that for for your contribution the
the final respondent is dr. Gavin
Schmidt who's a climate scientist and
director of NASA's Goddard Institute for
Space Studies and he is a senior adjunct
researcher at the Earth Institute
he works on understanding the drivers of
climate change
he was an orbital winner of the aju
climate communication prize in 2011 the
sky science communicator of the year and
his 2010 TED talk has been seen by more
than 1 million people thank you for
coming
thank you very much honored posts
respected guests so I'm going to talk a
little bit about climate change and the
impact that that has on on human health
and well-being NASA is one of the lead
agencies that monitors climate change
that studies the processes that underlie
our understanding of how the climate
system and the earth system works that
builds the models that are used both to
go back into the past and understand why
things have changed before and why they
are changing now climate change is often
thought of as a purely physical
phenomena changes in the temperature in
the rainfall in the winds and the storms
but at its heart climate change is a
human problem because all of those
things do not occur in a vacuum they do
not occur in a in on a planet where
there is no society where there is no
infrastructure our concerns about
climate change are associated not just
with the intellectual pursuit of
understanding but with the very real
impacts that climate changes have on
people societies and ecosystems now when
it comes to human health the impacts of
climate change ranged from the obvious
and perhaps not that serious to the
indirect and perhaps devastating we can
all think of what happens to human
health in places where there are greater
numbers of heat waves you know people
who suffer through heat and
a classic example in Europe in 20 in
2003 where tens of thousands of people
died and prematurely because of a
heatwave and an insufficient amount of
preparation air-conditioning and and
looking after people we can see people
drown when there are flooding events we
can see people injured by strong winds
this last month has been a catalogue of
direct whether perhaps climate impacted
events taking their toll on directly on
human health but I think the more
worrying and the more concerning aspects
are the indirect ones what happens to
infrastructure when there are increases
in intense reciprocation what happens to
infrastructure when there are increasing
numbers of heat waves what happens to
societies and systems and utilities and
powerlines and sewage systems when there
are large flooding events those are the
kinds of indirect impacts that lead
directly to health consequences one of
the biggest problems in Miami in
miami-dade County is the fact that when
there is flooding there is an enormous
amount of sewage that's kept in septic
tanks because most of the houses are not
connected to proper sewage lines so when
the waters flood and the waters rise
it's not water it's sewage in Houston
when the waters rose they flooded
chemical plants and again producing
slicks of not water but toxic pollutants
these have very direct health impacts on
local populations
there are other aspects there are
disease vectors there are pests there
are parasites whose life cycles depend
on certain aspects of the climate the
temperature the weather it gets cold
during the winter or not as a big factor
in the pine bark beetle outbreak again
which is leading to increased risk of
fire again another health impact so the
indirect impacts of climate change on
systems that are perhaps already
stressed by many other stressors are
going to be and this is a prediction are
going to be the biggest impacts now our
ability to assess the costs and the
damages associated with these indirect
impacts of climate change is it its
infancy there's great work being done at
this University and others on trying to
link these things together and to try
and get estimates of these indirect
costs but it is still very very much a
work in progress and one hopefully that
the the new Institute will will be able
to address more thoroughly than has been
done before but we can also step back a
little bit what are the causes of
climate change what are we what are we
actually doing to create climate change
we're burning fossil fuels and we're
DeForest stating deforesting those
actions have in themselves other
indirect health impacts when you burn
fossil fuels in internal combustion
engines you produce NOx you produce smog
you produce greater numbers of bronchial
problems asthma and associated issues
with air pollution when you increase the
amount of carbon dioxide in the air you
increase the acidity of the ocean
affecting communities and ecosystems all
across the surface ocean
when we change how we how we practice
agriculture and we increase the amount
of nitrates in the system that goes into
the that goes into the waterways it
impacts algae it impacts blooms and
impacts again human health when we're
looking forward and we're seeing what
our choices are as societies to mitigate
to adapt we have to be able to put all
of these things together to assess not
just what the climate impacts will be in
the direct and indirect impacts of the
climate but also what the direct impacts
of the actions that we're taking will
have we've done analyses for the UN
environmental program that demonstrates
very very cheap measures to reduce black
carbon methane emissions can have
enormous benefits not just for climate
not just for air pollution but for human
health and for the economy directly even
if you don't include all of those
indirect climate effects that I
mentioned earlier but again we are at
the beginning of thinking in a joined-up
way about all of these different things
climate is one stressor that is adding
to others inequality war economic
collapse and it is not necessarily the
only driver or the single cause of many
of the problems that we are going to see
but it is going to be increasingly one
of the key and important elements in
those events and so when we're doing
that preparation when we're stress
testing our systems we need to be
factoring in the sea level rise we need
to be factoring in the flooding we need
to be factoring in the changes in
disease vectors and the impacts that it
has on at the same time
this is a huge huge challenge both
intellectually and societally
Jeff mentioned how difficult it can be
when you have situations or topics that
are heavily politicized climate change
is one of those topics but that should
redouble our enthusiasm and our promise
to do a better job on incorporating all
of these factors into the global health
agenda going forward
thank you very much dr. Schmidt and
ladies and gentlemen this is what we'll
do now I'll start discussion and we will
have panelist respond to some questions
that I'll begin with and we will need
some time for depending on how much time
we have but we should take at least
three questions from the floor towards
the end and we will close at 6:30
promptly and so if I might just begin by
saying the following that the u.s. spins
United States spends 14 billion dollars
on on global health that's excluding on
itself the UK spends 4 billion and the
budget of the wh always between 1.9 and
2 billion most of the world depends on
the wh o for health in response to
emergencies and with the amount of money
that the wh o has it is I'm sure
severely stretched in many ways and so
the question I'd like to pose first to
dr. Ted Rose is in which ways will he
increase the revenue flow from member
states in terms of their fees and in
terms of voluntary contributions for
programs and how in in this new world of
of public-private partnerships what
smart ways there are that it has I'm
sure in mind in in forging
collaborations with a whole range of
players in the global health area I'd
like to draw on dr. Sachs to respond to
the question of financing as well but
simply to pose the question what is what
is what is his view what is it izip
approaches what are the new ideas in
terms of
generating more revenue for the WHL to
do its work thank you
I think the financing will depend on
whether Member States believe that ably
just in relevant or not and I think from
many of the meetings and today in the
presentation also WS relevant relevance
nobody actually questions it for our
global insecurity a multilateral
organization like whu-oh is very
important
so everybody underlines then if that's
true
it starts from there then you have to
resource it simple because if you
believe that this organization is yours
then you have to commit to pay for its
activities and there are some things
we're putting together now in order to
address to address the financial
problems not only asking from member
states but also some things internally
number one I think prioritization is
important that creates value for money
so the ability should be able to
prioritize what it does and focus on
major important and high-impact issues
that's one number two in addition to the
traditional donors expanding the donor
base is important and we have already
seen signs that some countries are
willing to contribute number three even
with the existing donors the funding
should be flexible flexible funding
sometimes you have some money your
market for something but you have
shortages for other things that's a
priority actually for the organization
and WH you should own its own business
and should be trusted by the Member
State
so basket funding more flexible funding
is very important but in addition to
that we need to move into new mechanisms
also innovative financing you say
private sector private sector is key we
have to involve private sector as a
source of fun financing also of course
it shouldn't be in a way that affects
the normative functions because the
normative function should also be
firewalled so there should be a balance
that's something that we have seen maybe
you can give me some feedback is the
innovative financing could increase
actually more resources to whu-oh one
area is tablature is a knowledge-based
so how can we use ICT I have met with
Facebook and GSMA and they're willing to
help in using those platforms beat
mobile or the Facebook Google in order
to raise funding for whu-oh you may not
believe it for instance our colleague
was saying panic and neglect and during
panic a lot of money comes because
that's during actual epidemics but as
soon as that spawned there is neglect
and from the contingency fund we need
four WH 100 million US dollars there is
a deficit of more than 50 percent so
it's really sad so there should be a
flexible and sustainable financing and
that we believe should include the new
financing mechanisms innovative ones
that should be sustainable and flexible
true so we are exploring all the avenues
but including the Member States which we
expect should increase both assist and
voluntary contributions
then the last part on financing is there
is a finance dialogue with member states
to raise funding that model doesn't work
because it puts WH on one hand on one
side and members on the other side WH o
begging and member states as donors but
WH as objectives are member states
objectives so there is no us and them
there is us so member states should take
responsibility in raising funds so the
model should change that's one one thing
that we are underlining the member
states are considering this seriously
the second is when we discuss about
raising funds for W Jo instead of
starting from financing w jo we should
start from discussing about financing
Robles agenda the big envelope itself
within that what's needed for W is just
a subset so into our resource
mobilization we're bringing these two
major shifts one it's not us and them
it's us so member states have the
obligation to raise the funding and two
when we raise the funding we have to
raise enough funding for the big
envelope which is resources up enough
for the global health agenda and within
that resourcing WH o based on its needs
so based on these shifts we have already
started there with the member states and
within some good science and we will
push in that direction but I would be
happy to listen to what Jeff says and
he's already helping me so he knows this
better it's his territory and he
promised to continue to help tablature
and that means
thank you thank you very much for that
could dr. Sachs in your response could
you also address the question of of
children and the Millennium Development
Goals around child health and the
relationship between UNICEF which is
responsible for child health and the
w-h-o responding to the question of our
financing almost everything that's said
about financing in the public debate is
confusion we had it when Trump yesterday
said how the UN is bloated and we're
gonna need to see cuts and so forth the
u.s. contribution to the UN to the basic
budget is six hundred million dollars a
year that's seven and a half hours of
Pentagon spending so there's nothing
bloated we're starving the international
system it's not a bloated system we're
starving it the thing that we're not
starving is this military machine where
the Senate yesterday disgracefully voted
a 700 billion dollar budget even more
than Trump asked for and to go beyond
Trump you have to really be crazy I'm
afraid so this is the first point we
don't use our wealth at all sanely and
not as people think and not as we need
to do so we under invest incredibly in
this a second point that you know was
taken for given is each country should
look after itself
this is pressed all the time this is
bogus we should look after each other
and we need to have we need to break
this ain't Rand
which comes from this country she's a
lousy novelist that is confused for a
philosopher only in America do you want
a philosopher go read Aristotle okay
Ain Rand is poor fiction but this idea
you know you're on your own really
permeates the global discourse and even
in your charts there wasn't poverty
there every country's supposed to have
their plan well some countries can't
have their plan I looked at the
countries I know those countries they
don't have a budget to do this stuff but
if I go to OMB even under the Obama
administration it was impossible to get
this stuff so we have to be realistic
always looking at what our needs and
what the budgets are and we have to
break the myth that this should be left
to the private sector I went to Facebook
a couple of years ago I said I want help
on global education they said why are
you coming here you go to Washington
we're a business I was ok I said you pay
your taxes I'll go to Washington and
then I was thrown out of the building
we've got a game going on these
companies don't pay their taxes they're
all in their tax hideaways which by the
way now they're gonna have to visit
their money some other place because
they've all been destroyed by the
Hurricanes which is where the hedge fund
industry resides so I don't know what
they're gonna do to visit their money
this week and we don't have the public
revenues and we have a myth also that
the government should not be the one to
do things it's not efficient but if you
look at the great scientific
breakthroughs that have come for the
last 75 years they have come in
government work thank you
whether it's in NASA well represented
here whether it's in DARPA we get a lot
of great innovation out of the Defense
Department because that's the one place
that we invest our public money
fortunately they do if some civilian
work as well
National Institutes of Health and so we
should be putting a lot of money into
whu-oh to help oversee an R&D agenda but
this is almost unimaginable right now so
the truth is and I'll just stop here
we're so rich you cannot really believe
it until you walk in Midtown especially
on the east side then you know it
because things are booming here there's
so much wealth you can't even imagine
the restaurants are packed I wonder how
many hundreds that you see how do they
pay these meals because there's a lot of
wealth but no one's paying their taxes
right now and the taxes if they are paid
are going to the military and then we're
hearing this rot like we hear from the
president who's a very confused person
anyway but someone gave them something
to say that says the UN is bloated it
turns out apparently his Justice golf
trips are gonna cost the taxpayers more
than 60 million dollars a year maybe
well more than 60 million
by one estimate more than a hundred
million dollars a year so that's a good
place to start also for innovative
financing Donald Trump could pay for his
own golf trips and maybe the US
government could pay for w-h-o but my my
other my other advice would be seriously
the u.s. is now the drag on the whole
international system
it says no to all finance and then it
says to others you don't pay either
because we're ex-air we don't want to
lose our veto we don't want to lose this
so it tries to hold everybody to minimum
right now I'm looking forward to the day
when China's gonna amply fund these
institutions India's going to amplifon
these institutions other countries are
going to amplifon these institutions if
the United States doesn't want to do it
everybody will know
okay we'll all survive it's not such a
big deal because there's a whole rest of
the world but the US should not let what
is absolutely necessary hold back the
rest of the world now we can't this
craziness that's coming from this
country cannot be the limiting factor
for the financing we need so there
[Applause]
you must certainly thank dr. sacks for
his leadership on these issues if I can
turn to dr. Cameron and just ask the
following question global health
security agenda was financed through an
emergency congressional appropriation of
a billion dollars and next year and so
the question is what is the appetite
in the current political environment for
replenishing yes so I'd like to ask her
that question and just as a side
question to the to the issue of
financing and the role of the US
military in medicine it's the US
military plays a huge role and a
positive role some of the discovery
science and vaccine development I think
of what they do it also read Institute
quite extraordinary work in the area of
disease detection as well globally and
so on and the issue politically is how
one leverages that and so I'm asking the
question how what is your view of how to
leverage that side of the funding
without compromising spending on health
as a public good because it's often the
criticism that health security has
dominated by military involvement
focuses much more on the security side
rather than the public side in terms of
health
thank you those are both great questions
and I'm happy to to answer them so I
think in terms of the US government
funding to take the first question first
so the US government received
approximately a billion dollars for
global health security in the middle of
the Ebola outbreak and that was pretty
extraordinary to be honest with you
because it was forward thinking it was
looking at the future while in the
middle of a crisis and so it was really
hard to get that funding out of a
Republican Congress
I will tell you but but they they
provided it the critical point with that
funding though was that it was tied to
specific metrics that needed to be
achieved by the funders in cooperation
with the governments I don't mean to
imply that all of those metrics were on
the countries they were also on our own
our own spending to make sure that we
understood what we were doing and that
it would actually help build sustainable
capacity that would help implement the
ihr and that was essential the Office of
Management and Budget looked at the
global health security agenda and its
targets that had been built before the
funding came in and made the decision to
ask for that funding because they knew
that it could be measured because there
were some targets that had been achieved
and because w-h-o and others were
already at the table so that was
essential I think that in order to
maintain funding for global health
security in the current climate and I
will say that the Trump administration
has supported this issue rhetorically
they've said they support global health
security and the global health security
agenda I think in order to see funding
for this there has to be an
extraordinary effort to advocate for it
and for Congress to provide it and to be
able to show that it is a common good
that is essential for global peace and
security and u.s. national security I
think those arguments can be made but I
think that the funding needs to come in
for CDC and USAID and the budgets that
are already out there for Department of
Defense and state to be at the table and
global health security needs to be
maintained because the multi sectoral
budget that we have helps bring multiple
sectors to the table in other countries
and that's very helpful
when when you're having financing
conversations and when you're trying to
look at measurable goals I'll take this
opportunity though to quickly respond to
to what dr. Sachs said as well I I
completely agree with you that not all
countries can do this on their own and
absolutely shouldn't but I do think that
every country every country that has a
government recognizing their our
countries and populations in the world
that they don't have that luxury at the
moment
can look at the planning that's but it's
been put in place and w-h-o has worked
in in in places all over the world
including countries that absolutely
can't finance this for themselves like
Burkina Faso to put together a health
security plan and how security plan is
tailored to their priorities and needs
and that's vital and I think that that's
helpful in bringing sectors of
government in places that otherwise
wouldn't be able to focus on this issue
but providing them that help and support
and that's a place where w-h-o and its
local leadership has been absolutely
essential and so when we look at
supporting w-h-o which is critical we
should be looking not only at support in
Geneva and not to imply that you said
that at all
but we should be looking at supporting
the w-h-o local offices and the experts
that are on the ground working there and
also supporting how they plug in to the
broader donor effort because they can't
do it alone either they do need the
donor government to help but we need
them there as well to be the glue and
then quickly to respond to your question
on military and Department of Defense in
particular involvement so I am I one of
the roles that I've played in the US
government was in overseeing u.s.
funding through DoD for biological
Threat Reduction which focuses on
biosurveillance biosecurity I also
worked closely with the defense health
programs that have laboratories all over
the world some of which have been
standing in places like Cairo and
Thailand and Kenya for more than 50
years and the way that those programs
are most successful is when they are
integrated into the fabric of the
societies in which they work and so in
in Cairo when I would visit Egypt the
w-h-o office for M row the national our
overseas laboratory Naval Medical
Research Unit Namur III and our own US
government programs worked hand in glove
and so in some situations that I was in
people would say I'm really worried
about the Department of Defense
involvement but I welcome Nambu three
and that's where you want to be you want
to be in a situation where those experts
are part of the fabric working with WH o
working
the host governments it's really really
important that we continue our
investment in those areas but that we do
it not at the expense of lines for
Centers for Disease Control that we
don't do it at the expense of USAID or
or the w-h-o but we need them right now
most of the US government spending for
global health security including in
places like Liberia where the Department
of Defense is helping build a central
reference lab with that government that
funding is from the Department of
Defense I'm not saying that's the way
that it absolutely should be but it's
really important it's helpful in
building safe and secure facilities and
it's helpful because it is at least
funding and we need it I'd like to turn
to dr. Schmidt on the question of
climate change and climate information
and environmental information and and
some of the practical things beyond what
it is he described in a second
but by focusing on what's been often
described as market failure in the
delivery of vaccines and medical
countermeasures when it's needed it's
particularly true during emergencies and
catastrophes and I'd like us to remember
that it's not just pandemic infectious
diseases but it's also accidental
chemical spillages or deliberate or
biological spell of is some more
deliberate radiological and so on is a
whole range of threats and they all
require a degree of hospital readiness
in order to cope with it and and they
require very importantly the delivery of
vaccines of course which prevents an
infection I'm taking hold and medical
therapies to deal with disease once it's
broken out and so to start off with with
you dr. Schmidt can you tell us what
would be helpful to know about climate
in order for people who deliver vaccines
for example globally it's a logistical
question
what do you say should know about
climate variability that will allow them
to plan firmly effectively especially
when you're dealing with with
emergencies okay let me see if I can say
something intelligent so one of the
problems that exists in delivery of
vaccines and another medicine to to the
more flour flung and miss connected
parts of the world is that we don't
actually even have good weather
forecasts for these places because we
don't have enough in sits you on the
ground measurements of temperature and
rainfall and the winds that would be
able to feed into the global models that
produce the forecasts that can be useful
and so our our ability even to forecast
the weather in places like Central
Africa is is much poorer than our
ability to forecast the weather in the
US or in Europe those are things that
can be fixed with you know increasing
investments in automated weather
stations we had there was a project with
Ericsson that Columbia worked with to to
put automatic weather stations on cell
phone towers so that as the cellphone
towers reached further in then more
information would be coming back as well
I don't think that the kind of more
long-term projections that we are
working on you know at the 2030 foot
here level are really of particular help
in you know immediate logistically
issues but the whole notion that you
need to be thinking about the
environment in which you're going and
being able to track what's going to be
happening there when it's going to
happen even in the short term is
obviously something that we work quite a
lot on
thank you very much for that I mean it's
it's a general problem right so there is
market failure in terms of of getting
back sins to the right place at the
right time but it's a bigger question
that was raised by dr. Ted Rose in terms
of having a pipeline of medical
therapies available that is proactive
and the w-h-o is a whole long list of
what is most likely outbreaks that would
occur in the area of infectious diseases
and so you can go into the website you
know to see that you mentioned it in
your talk how how do you how do you see
stimulating research and development
when it comes to vaccine development and
so it's an R&D process and there has to
be a pipeline that's available to
produce those vaccines I mean what is
what is the perspective on the part of
the whu-oh to help with that process on
[Music]
vaccines and research I think it will be
important first of all for those with
public health importance government
should invest governments should be
willing to invest because there are
market failures where the private sector
will never go into that territory so
that's one and the second for those that
have some interest in the private sector
I think the advanced market commitment
that gabby is doing would be important
to a combination of the two so
governments plus the advanced market
commitment for the private sector this
will really help by the way on the drugs
for hepatitis C one
area is general so we're doing that and
hundred twenty US dollars so that will
will help and we can go to elimination
now so in addition to generic I think
building the manufacturing capacity of
countries is important especially in the
developing world it and as you know
under the go global program many
manufacturing industries are migrating
out of China and that's very good
opportunity with the increasing wage in
China some industries migrating towards
the developing world and that could be
used to increase the manufacturing
capacity of the developing world
industrialization can come with that and
industrialization as you know means
innovation too so I think using those
opportunities will be important so that
could be applied for drugs
that could be applied for vaccines as we
know many of the expensive medicines or
vaccines at the end of the day the issue
is we the supply and demand issue so if
there is if we increase supply then the
price could be lowered and that's why
increasing the manufacturing industry of
developing world could increase
competition can bring competition and
that can can can help so long term I
think we have to consider those course
there was a high-level panel
recommendation last year and there are
some recommendations made by the high
level but these are the strategic
solutions that we need to to check the
climate change on climate change in
terms that's one of the pillars actually
in my priority when I was campaigning
or this position on climate change and
health maybe I would like to raise two
issues one doublet is focused mainly on
adaptation that's wrong of course it
should work on adaptation but it should
do more on mitigation the health impacts
of increased carbon release I think and
its impact on health WH er should really
raise the alarm
so more advocacy and very vocal one on
mitigation because mitigation is
prevention
nwj is for prevention so we cannot just
be on adaptation and only you know fix
the problems at their rise which we
cannot fix anyway and climate change is
a serious problem it's a problem for the
whole world but at the same time also
it's a problem for the whole orden and
all countries but there are countries
that are more affected
disproportionately affected than others
so which we need to help those with a
sense of urgency and these are the seeds
the small island developing States and
they have to be supported in wh-which
starting a new initiative SIDS climate
change and has initiative and we will
give them more support because they are
disproportionately affected and that
initiative will have programs and
projects that will come from the seeds
themselves
no one should prescribe to what to do
they should be the ones who should tell
us how we can help them and we can
facilitate and help so this is one of
the initiatives we are going to work on
and Columbia University I know we will
help in making this succeed but we have
to really help those who really
disproportionately
so I just like to just stick for a
minute on the question of vaccines you
you may have noticed that as novi past
Earwood through the development of the
clinical trials in fact for two vaccines
for Zika and what I said was two reasons
one was the epidemiology of Zika and the
second was the erratic statements by the
Trump administration because the whole
question of the production of vaccines
has been a boom and bust business so
when is a crisis there's a lot of
efforts a lot of money put into it and a
minute herbs is the climb so and so it
is a risky investment so the question is
how do we get a promised stable funding
in the vaccine business and I raise it
as an issue and I thought that it's part
of your response Jeff you might be able
to comment on that too I think about
another vaccine case half century ago 60
years ago which was the polio epidemic
and they're actually Franklin Roosevelt
created what became called the March of
Dimes the March of Dimes funded Jonas
Salk his research at University of
Pittsburgh when he came up with the
vaccine he was asked famously so who
owns the vaccine who owns the the patent
and he said the public of course he said
could you patent the Sun you know well
that's a wonderful sentiment the vaccine
was made public it went to a rapid
application the epidemic was ended in
the high-income countries now we're on
the verge of full eradication but the
point is that it was it's a different
intellectual property development model
obviously the public Channel and because
of the challenges of vaccines they're
tremendous public goods aspects and
therefore very poor people and the
market risks and and the fluctuations
there should be a massive public effort
for development of vaccines and there
we have Gavi there can be a research arm
that's attached to Gabby as a as a as a
mechanism of this I wanted to say
another word about the climate issue and
aid we talked about aid for hard-hit
countries but if this were a court of
law those countries would have claims
damages for what in law would be called
the public nuisance that their right to
their land has been damaged by outside
tortillas interference in this case by
the rich countries so we have an
obligation to pay I we call it under the
Paris climate agreement losses and
damages which is a category but when the
rich countries negotiated that they said
this is not compensation but of course
it's compensation should be compensation
because the overwhelming responsibility
for the climate change is not the small
island developing States or the Sahel or
the Horn of Africa or the Caribbean and
others it is the rich countries you can
even find the companies involved because
Exxon and Chevron are at the top of the
list of historical responsibilities so
they should be nabbed directly in court
for their responsibility so this is we
have to change the language and again it
comes back to this idea that somehow we
think that we're immune to
responsibility but we have to actually
be held to account for the
responsibility so I want to put aid not
as the relevant category here I want to
put accountability and compensation as
the as the relevant category thank you
very much I just got a note to say that
dr. Ted Rose is another engagement and
he has to leave like right now
so I was hoping to get at least two
questions from students and I'm gonna
ask you to please come to the microphone
so I'll introduce myself very quickly um
I also have a question a follow-up
question for professor Stax can i maybe
ask that after dr. Ted Rose leaves you
can put the question quickly okay
so thank you so much for being here I
actually used to be at the United
Nations I was a former adviser to the
group of friends for gender parity so
we're almost over a hundred countries
now who are advocating for a gender
equal leadership of the UN Secretariat
and it was in my conversations with one
of your predecessors Gro Harlem
Brundtland which is the reason why I'm
here now and pursuing a degree in
medicine first as a postdoc pre-med
student and so my question is with this
growing pattern of isolationism
worldwide and with the lack of funding
that we've talked about a lot there are
major gaps in the global health agenda
and where exactly the private sector can
fill in those gaps not just in terms of
raising funds and financing certain
aspects of it but in terms of the R&D
process or maybe donating certain drugs
that are in need in certain places which
is difficult and then leads into my
second question to Professor Sachs could
you could you mind holding on your
second okay sure I'm gonna ask dr.
Terrace to respond we have to be failure
unfortunately does have to leave I'm
gonna ask them to respond to that and
I'm afraid there won't be any further
questions and just how you can
incentivize before you just speak right
no no no this isn't very question just
to complete the question to dr. Ted Rose
how you can incentivize the private
sector to be involved and take ownership
in this global health agenda thank you
[Music]
yeah so I can
well ah you're giving me only one okay
no thank you
but it has actually two questions I
think you raised the gender parity issue
and then I don't know why you forgot it
I thought that was the question anyway I
can reframe it like a question I mean
are you going to do gender parity in
your top leadership no my question is to
clarify there are major gaps not just
financing and funding in the global
health agenda and how the private sector
can fill in those gaps that you could
identify and then also how you can
incentivize the private sector to take
ownership in the global health agenda
and be a part of your solution by the
way one of the opportunities we have is
the fencer it's a framework to engage
the private non-state actors private
sector being being one so we have that
framework that was endorsed it last year
so based on that that opens up
opportunities to engage the non-state
actors and we will try to benefit from
their contribution but we have to I
think one thing I need to admit is WH er
is a bit afraid of engaging the private
sector I think that's what you're up to
and we shouldn't really be worried by
that there shouldn't be even any
condition to engage the private sector
we know where the conflicts of interest
may arise we should be conscious about
that but there shouldn't be fear in
engaging the private sector so it's it
all starts from there we have to change
the mindset and we have to believe that
we we can work with the private sector
while still safeguarding the areas that
should be safeguarded or really managing
the conflict of interest but to do that
for the private sector we need to have a
clear
a strategy based on the priorities that
we have to seek their engagement first
we should know our priorities and then
put sit down and discuss on these
priorities and the engagement should not
be at the global level only it should go
up to country level on how the
partnerships could really benefit the
global health agenda which is a priority
for all of us including the private
sector so this is the framework we're
trying to follow and I have already
spoken to some of them in the last 17 79
days I have started my new post and the
engagement I had was very very candid we
had a very candid discussion it all
starts there we need to be honest with
each with each other so we will involve
them in many of the major issues that
that we have and we will need their
support
it shouldn't depend as you rightly say
just finance only many areas where we
can really partner but our partnership
should be based on trust and also very
candid discussions and honest
relationship and genuine partnership
thank you thank you very much dr. tetras
we now have to release dr. Ted Rose as a
former politician understand about
exactly those means and so so we have to
do that I'd like to thank him for coming
[Applause]
and just say that as is walking out that
it's it's very of the greatest
importance that we support the work of
the WH o it is the only global body with
universal legitimacy and anybody wants
to do any work any way in the world
requires diplomatic cover from the WH o
and therefore it's really quite
important for us to support him in his
work
so we'll we started late and with your
indulgence I'm gonna run toll till
twenty five to seven to get give the
students a chance to put questions and
so if I can ask you please to put your
question as crispy as you can okay hello
my name is Luke Nelson I'm a student
here at the college I'm a junior student
studying psychology last summer I was a
knife at fellow won a few undergraduate
students who got the chance to go to
Haiti and study maternal health care and
accessibility to maternal health care
and I had the chance to like retrain
community health care workers and just
sort of provide quality control and sort
of the work that they do however one
thing that I did notice was a sense of
discouragement and a sense of sadness
surrounding their issues and sort of
tiredness in terms of the efforts and
the work that they actually do so I
guess my question more specifically is
within the global discourse and with
with Haiti's economic dependence on
emergency funding and sort of the
lowering of funding throughout the years
by organizations like the USAID and
other private sector funders what what
goes into sort of ranking and sort of
understanding which countries take
priority in terms of the help and the
sort of sort of the work that is needed
to be done within that country but also
I guess like has the term global health
security been adopted to encourage
countries who can spearhead these
initiatives or more so like how do you
motivate these 70 plus countries given
all of the unique circumstances that all
of them do face thank you very much for
that question
I'll take professor Sachs so as you
described the u.s. is formidable food
industry system hurts us and overall
population health so I wanted to know
what you thought would be effective and
specific ways to respond to this the
food industry system and how it hurts us
if you can deal with that question dr.
Saxon on the question of Haiti if dr.
Cameron can respond to that in terms of
the global health security agenda I
wanted to say something about Haiti to
just that's fine go ahead just very very
very quickly there are two kinds of
answers to the question one is a kind of
formal textbook answer of which
countries are on which lists who needs
help and so forth
then there's the real answer which is
geopolitics i we don't care about haiti
period except if there is some kind of
refugee movement or if we want to
overthrow their government and so if you
actually look at how haiti got into this
unbelievably weird situation that it has
been and of course there are many things
going on but if you go back to say the
the early 90s
Aristide was overthrown okay then the us
put aresty back in and then the u.s.
said but you can't really stay in so
clinton put him back in but said you
have to leave right away so then they
put in praval and then aresty came back
and then george w bush said i want to
take out that guy so they tried to break
Aerys deeds government for five years
between 2001 and 2004 then they sent in
the CIA and they overthrew him and they
put him in a plane and carried him for
23 hours to Central African Republic and
if you check the New York Times would
not report that because they're in bed
with the CIA often so we couldn't even
get a straight story of a guy deposed in
broad daylight in our own hemisphere and
then okay they put in another one and
then massive hurricanes then massive
earthquake then mismanagement then Bill
Clinton in charge nothing recovered it's
unbelievable that's called geopolitics
it's we broke the country's economy by
repeated boycotts solve nothing and
there's some national responsibilities
along the way but basically we were
obsessed especially the Republicans were
obsessed with Aris deed for twenty years
and he was the only popular politician
in the country
and so if you have the only popular
politician you have to keep overthrowing
him you don't really create a base for
legitimate action so this is the real
story on food look we first of all
should say really what's going on and
I'll give you an example I last year the
top nutritionists in this country wrote
a chapter of their advisory report that
showed that a healthy environmental food
production system would also lead to a
healthier diet and that would be less
beef because beef is both destructive
environmentally and it's bad for the
health the amount that Americans are
eating it well the Obama Secretary of
Agriculture Tom Vilsack excised chapter
8 of the USDA said that's beyond the
recommendation boundaries because the
food industry apparently is important as
lobbyists and they didn't want to have a
chapter that spoke straightforwardly
about these risks we know the beverage
industry we know the beef I we were able
to take on trans fats because the the
nutritionists led a real campaign on
that and the companies were able to find
something different but basically there
are a handful of large companies here
that have a tremendous culpability in
the obesity epidemic and they need to be
held to account and they need to come up
with a plan for phasing out their
terribly dangerous products and we're
the only country if you look on the
charts and well we're not the only
country they're spreading it now to very
poor countries that don't have defenses
but we are so much above the obesity
rates of other high-income countries
because we're so much
more vulnerable to this kind of lobbying
thank you very much do you want to make
a comment on hey I'll be I'll be quick
and just say that and I'll say two
things one Haiti Haiti was prioritized
as part of the US government commitment
to assist at least 30 countries and
through that prioritization they are
developing a national plan with a lot of
assistance rightly so
from CDC and USAID and so that's
important it's a step forward but
obviously there's a lot of work to do
the second comment I'll make is just
that there isn't there to get to the
heart of one of the hearts of your
question I think which was a great
question I don't think there is
currently a reliable way to know how
countries fit with one another how they
rank in terms of their health security
and how that fits with with their
overall health system one of the
projects that we've been working on in
pilot since I've been at MTI in
partnership with the Economist
Intelligence Unit and the Johns Hopkins
center for health security is a global
health security index and whether it's
possible to create one and using
indicators not just from that not just
indicators that relate to pandemic
preparedness but indicators that also
track back to community health in the
overall health system and so we're just
completing the pilot phase of this
project but hopeful that a tool like
that would would help look at all of all
countries with a very transparent lens
so that better decisions can be made
about who's who's at risk and also what
the real risks are so we're including
political risk we're including a lot of
the other factors that go into whether a
country is prepared which are not just
factors that the governments themselves
control thank you very much so I'm
really sorry to keep you waiting I'm
gonna ask you if you can just put your
questions or three put your questions
very crisply and and we'll get the
panelists to respond and then close it
sir my name is Annette I am also an
undergrad I'm a sophomore in the college
so I spent most of my life growing up in
Ghana
and my question was about just what I've
noticed so I know that in Ghana there
are very very limited universities and
even with the universities we have very
few of them offer like medical programs
or have research sensors and whatnot so
that's obviously let's like a load
doctor to patient ratio and I imagine
that a lot of underdeveloped countries
experience the same thing so my question
is what efforts if any have like
international health organizations or
member states and who made to like
address this problem in countries
because if there are no doctors then how
really do you implement like health
reforms and what not thank you okay
thank you
hi I'm Matthew I'm a freshman in college
and I'm I was wondering
hearing all these all of these speakers
has definitely only reinforced for me
the need for funding for these for the
whu-oh for international organizations
and I fully sympathize with the need for
that funding but how do we bring these
issues to the average American or the
average citizen of any country so that
we can galvanize public support for
these programs that seem for a lot of
people I think to be very far off issues
so professor stacks I thought that it
was really interesting that you used
your introduction to talk about drug
pricing and you talked about the cost of
manufacturing of a drug but you didn't
talk about the cost of drug discovery
and just how long like simple statistics
like it takes 20 years to bring an idea
to you know an actual marketed product
and clinical the cost of clinical trials
and all those things so how can you
finance the drug discovery aspect of the
R&D process and also incentivize again
the R&D process and still come up with
you know drugs that are reasonably cost
I think that you would have probably
some really interesting things to share
on that thank you so thank you very much
for those terrific questions I'm going
to ask each one of the panelists to
respond to what they'd like to respond
to and make any closing remarks they'd
like to make starting with you dr.
Schmidt I'm just gonna pass the people
who know the answers to the questions
okay no other closing remarks debate I
don't need to talk just for the sake of
it thank you
I'll just I'll just be quick also on to
two points that don't perfectly answer
the question but in the interest of
passing along information that might be
helpful in the case of doctor to patient
ratio I don't have the answer to the
question about exactly what's being done
to tackle that issue on epidemiologists
and some of the other training programs
that I've focused on more in the global
health security agenda one of the the
answers to your question is that there
does need to be a concerted effort and
having a you know a standardized
approach to that and understanding what
the actual core gaps are and where they
are in the world and how to actually
tackle those gaps given all sorry
there's a big light there to tackle
those gaps in the context of what your
local needs are that's critical I also
want to just point you if you're
interested in health security Ghana has
been very active and has some
next-generation leadership support there
and and that would be an interesting
place to plug into if you're if you're
interested in that and then on on
vaccine development one of the
encouraging things that's happened over
the course of the last year is the
launch of the coalition for academic
preparedness innovation sepi which was
launched to get at some of the questions
that you raised how do you actually
shrink the time for drugs to get to
market for core for core drugs that we
really need to do any better vaccines
and therapeutics for but in my personal
opinion a lot more needs to be done to
get to to get to the point where we
actually have medical countermeasures
and diagnostics on demand which is
something we've been talking about for
years but we are really really far away
from one on the question of doctors and
and population because of mobile
connectivity telemedicine and
the advent of trained community health
workers there's a tremendous amount of
innovative redesign of how health
systems can reach everybody and so we
don't need doctors the same way as in a
traditional system we can have people
doing outreach
you can have your radiologists anywhere
in the world soon probably there won't
be even too many radiologists your phone
will do the reading of the images it
will both take the image and do the
image and interpret it through an expert
learning machine learning system so
there's a tremendous amount of
interesting innovation going on and I
would really encourage students to work
on systems redesign in an information
technology rich environment because we
can do a lot that was not even possible
just a few years ago
on the question of R&D I should have
added that Gilead in this drug that I
mentioned when it bought the product
probably the cumulative R&D that went
into safar severe was perhaps a half a
billion dollars Gilead is now earning
about 15 billion a year on on the drug
so the relationship between the R&D and
the ultimate pricing is not very direct
it's not very rational it depends
tremendously on market power and on
lobbying power and there are multiple
ways to get much better results but we
need what in in the lingo is called
rational drug pricing which explicitly
takes into account the R&D incentives
and the access issues the u.s. system
right now says we'll basically go out
and discover something and then you have
20 years of monopoly do what you want
and that system under any theoretical
conceptual terms
can hardly be what we call second best
it cannot be the right design there are
better more rational ways to keep that
balance one way by the way is public
funding and then open licensing of of
the medicines and this company that I
particularly despise Gilead for for many
reasons I despise that they leave people
to die I despise that they keep their
profits abroad in tax havens in a
complete tax gimmick and I basically
despise they don't do our and D almost
at all in I won't go into it anyway
we're not getting the best of this and
we're getting a lot of me to what's
called me to innovation meaning a
tremendous amount of duplication of the
R&D efforts because it's all designed in
a pretty irrational way to chase high
monopoly profit margins not to chase
social need so let me just say that it's
a lot of good considerations good senior
theses good PhD dissertations i many
trade offs but we're not even close to
getting those trade offs right right now
so thank you very much let me in closing
thank President Lee Bollinger and dr.
Ted Rose in the absence
and dr. sex cameron Schmidt for the
superb and thoughtful contributions and
we said he kept him told quarter to
seven as I have you I'd like to thank
volna Riviera Galaga and Jennifer
Gingrich from the world leaders forum
Peggy Dubner Gabby Flynn and one once
Annie Briggs Lopez for helping us set up
such a complex event and to all of you
for your interest in global health and
supporting the WHL and other
organizations advancing global health I
wish you good night
thank you for coming